vous remettre le document de valérie
pécresse c'est son projet tout juste
imprimer les 12 mesures phares de la
candidate les républicains doivent être
distribués pour tenter de convaincre
valérie pécresse n'est plus crédité que
de 10% des intentions de vote mais pour
son référent campagne en côte d'or la
partie ne fait que commencer je vous
cache pas que le début de la campagne a
été difficile parce qu'entre la crise
sanitaire puis la guerre en ukraine les
gens étaient pas franchement dans la
présidentielle d'où d'ailleurs à mon
avis des sondages parfaitement fossé et
là on sent quand même que voilà les le
temps est venu et les gens commencent à
s'intéresser sérieusement à la campagne
et puis aux propositions de notre
candidate ce qui me réjouit
déterminer encore l' envie d'y croire
les militants vont à la rencontre des
dijonnais certains encore un dc j'ai pas
trop suivi je suis avec les réseaux j'ai
vu un petit peu
on verra on verra bien avoir d'autres
déjà bien fixés sur leur candidat non je
vais pas voter pour élire
parce que je la trouve pas naturel juste
que c'est la meilleure de tous puisque
ce qu'on nous propose tant à gauche qu'à
droite
n'en guérit pécresse je soutiens je suis
juif un
tractage porte-à-porte programme déposé
dans les boîtes aux lettres un peu plus
de deux semaines du premier tour la
campagne de terrain va s'intensifier est
hors de question de penser à une
quelconque alliance avec la majorité
présidentielle valérie pécresse l'a
gagné l'élection présidentielle
en tout cas on m'a tout en oeuvre pour
qu'elle puisse gagner l'élection
présidentielle
la recomposition de se fera autour
d'elle et pour ne rien arranger valérie
pécresse vient d'être testée positive au
co vide elle devra poursuivre sa
campagne à distance